if you meet someone through an app like
that could also be a Divine encounter
too and so it's totally fine what does
your dating history look like I've tried
the things I've done the apps I've done
a lot of the friends introducing and all
that stuff but really it's only
culminated in one real serious
relationship for me but that's not in
that right now I think that like it's
totally normal to meet people through
the app and I think people around me
don't feel the same I feel like they
would think that like it has to be super
organic beautiful um every like like God
sent just dropped a person in your life
and that is your future and that is
everything what are your feelings around
going on dates I usually I don't plan
the date at all cuz I'm like I don't
want to know I don't want to show my
interest is knowing what you like and so
I already know what I like and so why
would I plan it and do something I want
to do I want to keep it open so I can
see what you like and then I can test
and be like do I like those things and
if I do we go on to a second day and
so